feels are all
kaylynn wasn't the only one who left
paradise but she was the only one who
left for love and that's at the end of
the day the biggest thing on Monday
night's episode of bachelor in paradise
it was clear that the pressure is on
for all the relationships left on the
beach as paradise comes to a close first
Kaylin took Dean up on his offer of
leaving to pursue a relationship in real
life yes ma'am
so what he's saying
do you leave with me
and everyone on the beach was in happy
tears over the pair's departure
[Music]
except Connor whose response was well
warranted to say the least
Dean and Kaylin have alluded to their
relationship on social media both
sharing sweet posts of one another on
the gram Kaelin posting this pic kissing
Dean writing in the caption a rare
moment where paradise actually felt like
paradise while Dean shared this solo
shot with Kalin's name on his chest
along with the caption missing baggage
if found please return to Kalyan I'm not
willing to yeah
fight it Kristina and Blake also left
the beach separately after he tried to
win her over one last time
[Music]
blake took to instagram shortly after
the show aired where he opened up about
the struggles he faced while in paradise
saying it was a rough experience and has
no one to blame but himself he also
admits he's still hopeful about finding
love quote i hope that this is not the
end of my story and i can look back at
this summer and be grateful for the
lessons learned and the friends made
[Music]